[Music]
although creare visibility' so through
our v2 v Bella ragazza live indeed
answer your prayers on a journey to
decorate la paz to confront our la if
you follow a daily aim quest mode of
Boise our only opportunity on Kilowog
the authority I tell you to not de-spawn
duriandurian canister Cristobal trader
deal of work and Bangor America posi
diversity through this lab we can meet
another artist in a different in
different country and they have diverse
background and skills we can share that
we can see how do they do and I can show
my skills too
[Music]
how do you communicate use the strength
of each person some people sitting in a
wheelchair but it doesn't matter there
are always possibilities to work with
the situation to work with a TV or to
work where the person to work with the
environment to work with everything you
see everything you can use to make your
piece it's very rare but also rich to
have such a diverse group together
during the artistic lab this week and
that means so much for the development
of all these artists the talent
development and therefore I think it's
very important that these artistic labs
are happening and it helps every single
one of them to to go back to their own
place and develop even further it's been
about heightening choreographers senses
I would say and that's been quite key
hasn't it just sensing what's going on
in the space and sensing how you are
working with your with your partner I
think that's really important and what's
really interesting is it feels like this
course is something that every
choreographer should do actually it's
something that everyone should should
practice I'm most interested when I see
work that's coming from
some new or strange or unexpected
perspective but for me this is the point
of art that we reimagine how we're
living what we care about what we do and
I think from my I can only speak from my
own perspective but I think living in
the world with a very particular
experience of the world makes you
immediately question does this have to
be like this
are there different ways and so I think
all the artists at this lab are kind of
pushing at their edges of what is the
expectation of their work what else is
possible and I think that any / any
artist who comes with a very unusual
perspective on the world has a lot to
offer and makes the most interesting
work
[Music]
for me it's about individuals having
voices and really strong voices and
being present and not being ignored and
not being sidetracked so that's that's
that the key for me is that there are
voices in the room and they are being
noticed and it's acceptable that they're
different and we celebrate the
differences
[Music]
you